now you may
only see a pile of boring forms and
numbers
but i see a story today we are looking
at all the details that went into making
everything everywhere all at once with
very few resources they managed to craft
a masterpiece ready to find out who was
in all the gorilla suits hello
number one with their micro budget of 25
million dollars they were working with
the 99 cent store equipment the entire
project was filmed in just 37 or 38 days
director daniel kwan one half of the duo
that makes up the daniels got a pocket
camera that shoots 4k and everywhere he
went he would just shoot the streets he
shot a bunch of stock footage cut it
together and then acted it out to
michelle yo then michelle had to do it
in slow motion set up in front of a
green screen they had led panels on
either side of yo showing what was
happening on screen they added a few
special effects in post like slow motion
streaks and shattering glass but
ultimately didn't want to pull attention
away from you
number two sometimes when you know what
you want you just gotta do it yourself
we ended up having almost 500 visual
effects shots for the most part all done
by only five people which is kind of
unheard of movies of this scale usually
have a whole army of artists working on
the special effects but once again when
you're working with a small budget
you've got to do a lot of the heavy
lifting yourself but with a movie as
crazy as the one that's quite literally
about everything everywhere it makes it
all the more impressive the vfx work
they did varied a lot from simple wire
removal to some visual effects that were
blended into the live action and then a
few sequences that were full-blown vfx
number three on a movie with a budget of
this size if they didn't use practical
effects it just wouldn't have gotten
made the first time yo does a jump and
connects to herself in another universe
was just one of their practically done
effects she shoots back in her office
chair and flies through a door the fun
thing about that shot is it's 100
practical in camera we didn't change
anything it was done in camera by
cranking open the shutter to get the
really nice streaks we had hidden a leaf
blower behind her and yell was pushed in
a wheelbarrow really slowly through the
office and had to freak out in slow
motion
number four this movie took hand puppets
too literally the raccoon and hot dog
hands were not done with cgi at all but
rather puppets the team enjoyed using
practical elements because they didn't
require the actors to act opposite a
tennis ball or pretend they had weird
fingers and hoped it worked out once the
cgi was added
number five if you hadn't seen this
movie and listened to this next part you
would be left with more questions than
answers when yo first learned about the
hot dog fingers she tried to have the
scene cut because it was just too absurd
but when she learned about the
she was like are you kidding me michelle
was thinking i'm a serious actor i have
done amazing movies and i'm rolling
around on the ground with a plug so i
must thank my directors for the most
amazing first time experience stunt
choreographer andy admitted let's just
say the situation of the fight scene was
so weird and out of this world that me
brian and michelle couldn't focus on
shooting without laughing in between
takes
number 6. successfully pulling off this
scene must have felt like acing a test
you didn't study for for quan the fanny
pack fight was tough not only had he not
yet landed the neck wrap with a kick
back towards the camera but they only
had limited shots to nail it given their
tight budget the pressure was on quan
said take two came and i'm thinking
please god let me do this right and i
did it on the second take he did every
move in that complicated fight scene
except one where he was happy to let a
stunt double step in
number seven you'd be wigging out too if
you had to make this many wigs the film
was meant to be a love letter to
michelle yo's career and so anissa
salazar pulled some of her inspiration
from joe's own filmography yo's looks
were made from a mixture of wigs and
hair pieces one of the most important
things to salazar was that she wanted to
make sure the wigs were consistent
throughout so even though michelle had
over 40 plus hair changes she still had
that individuality with all the rest of
the characters the toughest part wasn't
crafting the looks but rather pulling
them together on a tight schedule which
could include up to 10 changes a day the
hair stylist in the hot dogs for hands
universe was chosen by curtis from a
stock photo of a stressed out irs tax
agent salazar recreated the hairstyle
for curtis which she said would
sometimes look like lord farquaad from
shrek the bagel hairdo was designed to
look not just like a bagel but
specifically like an everything bagel
salazar wanted her to have this ethereal
kind of celestial goddess vibe and she
wanted to create something complex
saying the pattern i came up with
represents the depth of this character's
interior where it felt futuristic yet
unique yet a little chaotic to create
the look she added different layers of
beads there were foam cutouts wire was
used and she used multiple varieties of
braids from fishtail braids to bamboo
braids to normal braids and then they
added a 22 inch extension ponytail for
that dramatic length
number eight going prosthetic lists is
like going commando in the hollywood
universe jamie lee curtis was keeping it
real and refusing to wear any
prosthetics for her role as the weird
irs inspector juan said everyone assumes
that her belly in the movie is a
prosthetic but it's actually her real
belly she was grateful that she was
allowed to just let it out immediately
after signing up she started sending the
daniel's weird photos and hairdo ideas
dan was the one who found a photo online
of a real irs auditor and jaime fell in
love saying that's incredible please let
me be her please please please please so
that photo became the reference curtis
just wanted to be truthful to this woman
because as she said in the world there
is an industry a billion dollar trillion
dollar industry about hiding things
everything to conceal the reality of who
we are and her instruction to everybody
was i want there to be no concealing of
anything
number nine the range of costumes in
this movie is quite unfathomable some
costumes were pieced together from
shopping in los angeles chinatown some
came from amazon that is where they got
multiples of that awesome pleather fanny
pack kurata said as a costume designer i
think about where would she shop and
where would she get her clothes well she
would go to chinatown she admitted i was
really scared because michelle having
come from crazy rich asians what if
she's gonna expect all these expensive
designer clothes and i'm getting these
really inexpensive clothes from
chinatown is she gonna be upset but it
was the easiest fitting and i was so
grateful she was open to not the most
glamorous outfit when you're working
with multiple universes color palettes
become super important to keep one world
straight from the next so the
inspiration for the outfits in the hot
dog fingers universe was actually hot
dogs themselves beige and light pink
colors were used inspired by buns and
wieners porrowski's films were another
big inspiration number 10 there wasn't
enough space in a movie about everything
for this scene sorry in a very early
draft of the movie it opened with a
narration about everything hanging in
the balance relying on the present
moment there's a man whose job it is to
test football helmets there's a quantum
accident and he passes through a wall
convinced it's a miracle he keeps trying
to perform miracles until he's injured
by some robbers in some universes he
lives and in others he does not then it
switches to a football player mid-game
who if he catches the ball becomes a
cult leader and if he doesn't he becomes
a sad carpenter and he only finds
happiness in universes where tables can
talk it was a great opening but it did
not focus enough on the main character
to make it past the first draft number
11. we wonder if they'd realized what
they cut before it hit theaters if
they'd put it back in there was a second
scene that was cut where jenny slight's
character comes in with a weapon and she
and evelyn struggle over it evelyn turns
the weapon into a phone and brings up
jenny's character's family on facetime
where her son begs her to come to his
birthday party it wound up being
incredibly problematic when it was cut
because it left no rectification for
evelyn calling jenny's character a crude
term to put it lightly
number 12 we aren't talking about
fighting off the vid just beating that
march shut down in 2020 everything
everywhere all at once got incredibly
lucky because they finished their
principal filming when the rumors of
kovid were still just spreading on the
last day of shooting the crew pulled an
all-nighter getting the sense that
things were getting really bad they
finished their principal photography the
saturday morning before covet hit
they only had to push a few pickups and
green screen shots
number 13 the beginning came from a
surprisingly simple place dan quan said
i was driving with my fiance to big sur
because we were checking out wedding
venues that long ride going back and
forth up a mountain lulled me into a
state of thinking about high concept
sci-fi ideas
number 14 now it's time to reveal who
was under those gorilla masks it's
daniel shinert in the hot dog ape
costume striking the finishing blow to a
non-hot dog fingered ape the production
only had two ape suits so he isn't just
the lead ape in the sequence he plays
almost all of them and that was daniel
quan leading that ceiling smashing dance
in the video number 15. who's a villain
who's a baby who knows the name of the
film's villain jobu topaki came from a
list of interesting sounds daniel kwan
and his wife generated when they were
looking for a name for their daughter
do you think this is funny
if you haven't seen this movie yet and
for some reason listened all the way to
the end of all this gibberish do
yourself a favor and check it out if you
could visit any alternate universe which
one would you pick let us know in the
comments and thanks for hanging out with
us here at the things